I was informing how about the MBE thing
no I said that but the reason you were
awarded it because you're bringing
awareness to domestic violence you wrote
a book you have a great but the title of
the book is brutally honest actually
I've just written some more chapters oh
yeah I can tell you that I've just
written a few more chapters and that's
coming out soon you just have two
chapters com a few more chapters so it
updates like five more extra chapters so
it'll be like the the soft cover the
paperback yeah so that's coming out soon
I forgot about that yeah that's coming
out soon I just like and you opened up
not only do you have a charity but you
have a a a place for battered women or B
people in domestic violence shelters and
refuge I can never say it right Refuge
refugees well refugees is different than
ref I know I know that's why I always
say it wrong I have a place for them to
go Refuge a shelter a refuge a shelter a
refuge yeah so the these women and it's
just for women only and their children
you know if they escape their abuser in
the middle of the night they've got
somewhere to go and that is literally
down the street from my my house
specifically in the UK or in the US it
is well it's all over the UK but
specifically mine's in leads and then I
goang out and she goes there yeah I go
and have my th yeah yeah and you are um
Beyond doing that that is heroic because
not only uh was your life saved but I
think that when people hear the your
story and it it gives them because as
somebody who has not experienced that
what's amazing is knowing you like I did
you are scary you are Scary Spice you
seem you talk about girl power you talk
about anybody would think that you are
not like the person that could you are a
superhero domestic violence happens it
can happen to anybody no matter race
gender how rich how poor you are it can
happen to anybody literally you just I
don't know how much you want to share
but you came really close to death oh
yeah many times at the hands of my
abuser but that's kind of morbid to talk
about but it is an epidemic having said
that but it's about GL I get to share my
story and my message and you have three
kids yeah kid and they were they saw it
they witnessed it yeah my oldest one
Phoenix who is stunning and is now doing
um she does a lot of stuff for my
charity too she does modeling with me
too yeah yeah but you guys do you have a
campaign I saw some sort of campaign
with you in Phoenix and and uh the your
abuser is still out there yeah but we
won't give him a platform but yeah no I
won't mention and abusers don't stop
until they're actually physically
stopped by the court or the justice
system but the thing about the justice
system is it's all back to front they
need to redo the whole entirety when it
comes to dealing with the women in those
kind of situations because they they
haven't got a clue and they haven't got
the right support system in place I mean
the met police have stepped up in the UK
they're now educating people that go go
to houses where they've funded up and
like like said domestic violence now
they're being educated but you never
police I was too terrified and a lot of
women think that they're not going to be
believed so they don't go to the doctor
they don't go to the police they just
hang de life I've heard from I listen to
a lot of like True Crime podcast and a
lot of the time it starts with domestic
violence and a lot of the story say even
when they do go to the police don't do
anything until it's too late like you
have to a lot of the time yeah and they
won't do anything just that's all about
re-educating the whole system and
starting in Schools starting at home
being able to talk about it more openly
and freely because when I brought my
close to death I know that we saw you at
work with bruises and things you always
made excuses and I know your buddy Randy
was sitting here uh I think he's
responsible also for saving your life oh
yeah yeah he did I heard a story where
that you were actually dying and he
pulled out the phone and you wanted to
call 911 floor yeah wa it's 999 pardon
me it's 999 in England okay just in case
you ever need it all right that's good
to know it's informative yeah but they
got the point anyway not everything has
to be correct so yeah so that was that a
time in my life but the thing is with
the you live with it you know you can't
just pretend it never happened no matter
how much therapy you go to always there
so you have to live with it side by side
you think it affected your children
definitely definitely it's and if I'm
sure it still affects them to this day
but we have counseling we talk really
open about it and it's a thing where you
just end up living with it for the rest
of your life
unfortunately